alors monsieur legault lundi madame
anglade hier manon massé aujourd'hui
bonsoir madame macé bonsoir monsieur roy
vous allez bien ça va très bien mou mais
ça va très bien pandémie aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça vous a rassuré que la
coroner en chef disent on va aller
regarder ça de près nous l'idée c'est
dans les sièges à cette ba écoute et je
pense que vous savez le coroner est un
organisme indépendant c'est un des des
chiens de garde quelques bugs et donner
pour prendre soin de notre bien commun
et honnêtement que soit la vérificatrice
générale la coroner en chef qui est le
plus de gens possible qui nous aide à
comprendre qu'est ce qui s'est passé
parce que entre vous et moi c'est pas un
russe qui s'est passé non c'est pas
heureux et il ya eu on le sait le québec
mais on n'a pas fini de compter les
morts partout sur la planète mais on est
parmi les pires endroits pour ce qui est
des résidences pour personnes âgées ou
les en termes de décès quelques el hilal
quelles sont les questions les plus
urgentes que vous avez vous comme
parlementaire quand vous regardez la
gestion de la crise
ben c'est sûr que on le sait depuis
plusieurs années en son héritage libéral
les conditions de travail
là le manque de personnel fait en sorte
que la situation qu'on a vécu on aurait
pu l'éviter voudrait peut éviter pas
tous les morts j'en suis mais un bon un
bon normal d'aller explorer du côté peau
s'est-il encore aujourd'hui semble-t-il
que du déplacement de personnel d'une
zone à l'autre d'un csld alors ou d'un
lieu de soins et à l'eau cette enquête
on est encore trois mois plus tard les
préposés aux bénéficiaires ont encore
des conditions de travail et des
conditions salariales qui rendent ce
disciple je sais que ça va se régler
mais ça aurait pu se régler bien avancé
ensuite vous venez vous avez parlé juste
avant de la question de la climatisation
écoutez monsieur legault était ministre
de la santé et on parlait de la
climatisation des ch à celle d alors
oui j'ai hâte d'entendre ce qui va
ressortir de l'enquète pour les préposés
est ce que le poc a été fait salariale
pour vous on est arrivé à quelque chose
qui est équilibré qui commence à avoir
de l'alluré mais ce que cette temps des
1000 avons nous avoir fait ressortir de
ce roi sait comment les jobs de soins
dans les villes que ce soit les préposés
les infirmières les auxiliaires les
auxiliaires familiales
les enseignantes les femmes en service
de garde j'ai dû les femmes
ben c'est son cd job de femme c'est
diablo sont mal payés et en temps de
pandémie
on en fait des anges gardiens j'espère
qu'on va retenir cette leçon lors et si
le gouvernement du québec veut faire la
relance économique
ben qu'il oublie pas que les services
publics on en a besoin
c'est vraiment un point intéressant vous
soulignez parce qu'il ya eu des grandes
enquêtes d'un room dans le monde en
france le new york times ici il ya des
journaux qui l'ont fait aussi des sites
c'est un monde de femmes qui étaient en
première ligne beaucoup là beaucoup
beaucoup et on s'est aperçu que c'était
effectivement des salaires sous payés
bain et on s'est aperçu écouter j'aime
beaucoup ce sont à lui oui c'est ce que
j'allais dire parce qu'il me semble que
ça fait plusieurs années voire des
décennies que les femmes le disent et
moi de pichey québec solidaire on cesse
de répéter
là je vous ai parlé des services publics
mais on s'est rendu compte que la
caissière au métro à la pharmacie était
aussi une femme était aussi payé au
salaire minimum
alors si on ne reconnut que ces emplois
étaient des impôts essentiel qu'on a
même offert des primes tellement on
voulait signifier que c'était essentiel
mais pourquoi on l'emmène la crise
allait plus vous savez 60% des
travailleuses au salaire minimum sont
des femmes alors je pense que sauf si ça
pourrait être un geste quel gouvernement
pose s'il veut relancer l'économie
projet de loi 61 là vous êtes crêper le
chignon à québec l'opposition fait front
commun pour ne pas que cette loi ne soit
adoptée par ailleurs là à l'opposé
madame en a c'est est ce que c'est
normal que ça prenne 4 ans 5 en faire
une école faire un parc
je lisais l'autre fois que mm en beauce
où monsieur legault est allé faire un
parc pour les enfants la ce a pris 3 à 2
avant d'avoir toutes les autorisations
est ce pas normal non plus là ben écoute
et c'est ce qui fait ce nom c'est tout
le monde s'entend pour dire qu'on peut
raccourcir les délais sauf que ce qu'on
a dit les oppositions par rapport au
projet de loi 61 c'est que si ces
pauvres passés par dessus les lois qu'on
s'est donné pour se protéger pour
protéger l'environnement protégé les
finances publiques
ben ça c'est non ça se peut pas alors
donc nous on en a offert une solution au
gouvernement qu'il nos ports dénis
répondre c'est que si vous trouvez que
les délais sont trop longs
on vous comprend et lieu eu des
restrictions budgétaires dans tous les
ministères depuis des années et il
manque de personnel
alors allez-y embaucher des
fonctionnaires à l'environnement au
ministère du transport
au ministère on n'est pas et vous allez
voir les délais vont peut-être en partie
vous avez raison peut-être mais il ya
d'autres éléments comme les
expropriations c'est très très très long
est ce qu'il n'ya pas est ce qu'on n'est
pas dû quand même pour faire le ménage
dans certaines dans certains processus
sans rien à enlever des exigences vous
savez quoi
si les loups et qu'on a adopté par le
passé pour par exemple au sortir de la
commission charbonneau sont rendus des
lois qui aujourd'hui dérange les
promoteurs ben moi je me dis c'est
d'être mieux c'est peut-être mieux
et pour ce qui est par exemple des
délais je le réitère c'est pas con et
poker garder ça sauf que le gouvernement
dans son projet de loi 61 a demandé 100
% ou 98 pour ça des pouvoirs en août
inquiétez-vous pouvons utiliser juste 10
pour ça non ben oui c'est inquiétant
on a vu on a ouvert l'émission avec ce
un deuxième policier blanc qui est
accusé de meurtre à atlanta cette fois
ci est ce que ça fait des petits cette
histoire-là de mu flotte partout sur la
planète
est ce que le comité sur le racisme vous
dites c'est une bonne initiative
au-delà du débat systémique ou pas
est-ce que c'est une bonne initiative le
comité puis attendez vous des des
progrès de sa écouter d'aider des pistes
de solution on en a ça existe
les personnes restées les autochtones
depuis des années nous disent nous
points qu'est-ce qui va pas qu'est ce
qui doit changer
maintenant ça prend la volonté
collective de tout le monde de dire oui
on trouve ça indigne en devoirs que nous
conte citoyens autochtones racisées
vives de la discrimination
je mens plus que les personnes qui sont
au rsa et donc on veut ensemble prendre
à bras le corps ce problème là pour
trouver des solutions et moi dans le
christ et soit c'est bon comme steam
cependant on va on va juger aux arts ses
fruits
ouais c'est l'arbre à ses fruits
exactement le premier ministre dit qu'il
voulait aller rapidement
c'est pour ça qu'ils voulaient pas trop
consulter lorsque je dis c'est attention
les oppositions népal alors que si un
hacker qui reconnaît ceux qui
travaillent plus longtemps sur la
question du ressuscité mais que c'est
bien et nous et deuxièmement les
personnes concernées ou si donc qu'ils
le vivent ce racisme système etc la jaxa
ces personnes là aussi doivent faire
partie de la solution bien sûr bien sûr
manon massé chef parlementaire de québec
solidaire député de
sainte-marie-saint-jacques merci
prochaine au revoir aw